i've got this chart i had so oh okay you
might have seen it in my most recent
video so
what are your thoughts on the
accuracy of these ratings would you say
is there any disagreements you hold
obviously like in theory you would be
more educated in ranking men
as compared to um like obviously
probably give the guy the five in on the
top i'd probably give him a four
wait which one
that one yeah your mouse is over oh him
he
yeah he'd give him a four
yeah
everything everything else
so you think this guy's a seven these
guys are like eight to nine sort of
range
um
yeah probably yeah that's
yeah how do you feel about the uh female
rankings is there any disagreements
again
[Music]
um
sorry i know i cut out again i'd say the
girls are pretty accurate
um i'd maybe give the five
it's funny because i think this is
probably gonna go with what you
like guys would say about girls that
girls rank each other higher i'd
probably give the five in the middle one
up and give her a six you give wait
which one do you want the bottom the
bottom one i just i'd keep but the top
one
but this one you'd say is potentially a
six yeah but other than that like yeah
i'd say these are pretty accurate
i want to see what the audience has to
say
um
if you're watching this right now like
leave in the comments if you think
there's any like disagreement so just
say like top six is actually a four or
something like that if there's any
disagreements that you have then feel
free to leave that in the comments
uh but back to this would you say
overall like this is
fairly accurate in terms of ratings
yeah i mean it doesn't put height into
play but yeah oh yeah of course yeah so
okay
now let's yeah so let's delve a little
bit deeper into that so let's say that
this guy who you rated her for if he was
six foot two
would that bring him him up to a six
or seven or like yeah
yeah
okay
how about if somebody on the lower
echelons like would their height make up
for it so this guy if he was six foot
four would that
still like would that bring him up to a
five or would he still be a two because
he's lacking in the face
uh
i'd probably bring him up to like a
three or four i would say
oh so so do you think that
has a lesser impact if you're lower than
the lower in the look scale
because there's more
there's more prevalent issues at hand i
think that it affects like average guys
if an app like if an average looking guy
was tall i think he'd have more options
than like a more of an increase in
options than if like a two was tall
yeah i agree with that that makes sense
yeah yeah i agree with that point so
earlier i said that
looks is 50 face
30 higher 20 body for men but obviously
if you're in like the lower echelons of
attractiveness then like because your
face is holding you back the most
like your face is going to be like 80 of
the equation like because being frank
like if one of these guys was
six foot two six foot three or five foot
ten like it's not gonna make a
difference because there's such more
greater issues that need to be
resolved first before they can climb the
attracting scale
but then for these like guys in the
middle like if this guy was say six foot
three then that is going to be a huge
advantage potentially bringing him up um
maybe
like at least one and a half maybe even
two points in terms of like overall
rating
no i'd agree with that so
how about body then how do you feel that
that like fits into the equation so if
this guy
was um like ripped lean
i think that would bring him up
um
i don't think girls care that much about
body
so would you like it maybe like
it would maybe give him like
maybe from a five to a 5.5 or a six but
i don't think body helps that much
so based on the percentages that i
mentioned earlier so 50 phase 30 heights
20 body like would you change those um
i'd maybe do 40 height 10 body well
because like if you're heavy i think
that brings you down a lot but i don't
think getting jacked brings you up that
much does that make sense oh yeah so as
long as you're like um average build
like you don't need to be a six-pack
ripped but yeah as long as you're like
not significantly high body fat
percentage then then um
like other things such as price and
height it's gonna yeah
um but i also don't
even like if you're heavier i don't
yeah but like that would kind of make
sense with what you're saying i don't
think girls like care as much as guys
about a happier guy
about a sorry what sorry like a heavier
guy
oh oh seriously i would say it's the
complete opposite
i i completely yeah i disagree with that
point like quite significantly i would
say that um
men are discriminated way more for being
overweight high body fat compared to
women
um
how big are we talking i think is the
question um okay i think i've got
right
um
so the guy on are you still sharing this
screen because i'm not sure
okay so the audience will be able to see
what we're looking at right now so i
would say
um
the guy on the right like he is very
unattractive like he's going to get
rejected on his body purely because of
his weight meanwhile like this woman
would still be considered attractive not
as potentially as attractive like as
these two people but
a lot of men would still like feel that
this is acceptable but i think this is
unacceptable as a man
would you agree with that or would you
say that if this man is like his face is
naturally going to be like capped at
six
maybe even five purely because of his
higher body fat because it's gonna be a
lot of fat in his face but like if this
guy had a good height and average face
like five would you consider this man
date worthy or if he's still
if he if he had a good personality yeah
i think he would be date worthy
no no okay
what i mean by personality is basically
social status what i mean is i see funny
guys pull hot girls all the time
yeah like like you can't deny that like
comedians have hot girlfriends all the
time yeah again like
i'll start off by saying that
uh i think your credibility to the a lot
of the audience just went from like
very high to drop drop to like quite low
but i was just going to mention the
point you said earlier that um
again like you mentioned these comedians
who are able to attract women yeah this
is talking about like the 0.1 minority
like how many guys actually become
comedians rockstars
yeah
i'm tempted to just look i have a look
at the comments right now i just want to
hear what they're saying uh after you
pulled the can you see them you should
be able to see right no i'm
i'm guessing if i go to my uh go to the
stream watch the youtube video then they
won't be up won't be able to uh
see what you're turning on the screen
yeah i'm not sure
be
um
social status you mean like the
president right i'm reading is it
showing the stream right now or is it
showing um my powerpoint slides no it's
showing your powerpoint i just can see
um with the app we're in like on the on
the far right hand side you can click
comments and you can see them while we
like are going
oh that's good then so if i can read the
comments then um but i'm still showing
the powerpoint slides then that's ideal
yeah
it sounds like you did get a bit of
backlash um
there's a lot of uh
triggered people in the comments
yeah well when i i just see funny guys
like they're still able to get girls and
that's what i mean but you're right
they're probably in the top like 90.
yeah top top 0.1 yeah percent of being
funny so i could see what they mean by
that
yeah so going back to the original point
then um
so would you so you started off by
saying that
being high body fat percentage is less
of an issue for men as compared to with
women
so would you like to elaborate on that
further
less of an issue
what i mean i think of like i was
thinking in terms of being funny like i
don't think being a funny girl gets you
any points and like smv
i don't know i was i wasn't talking
about uh funniness or um
but that's what i'm
i was talking about like being
overweight yeah being high percent body
fat because i'm not
they said that like i'm not entirely
sure but i believe you made the case
that um
weight gain isn't as big of an issue for
men as it is with women
yeah is that correct
yeah that's what i do oh so so um sorry
is that what you believe like would you
like to elaborate on that further
um
no because i think you just proved me
wrong i'm not gonna
yeah thanks for being modest
okay
okay thanks for being modest um
yeah okay so i'll just i'll carry on
like i'll just elaborate a little bit
further on this but then we'll move on
to something else so i would say
the baseline
actually no not the baseline the the
desired
um
body for men is this the guy on the left
like this is what like 99 of women are
gonna find the most ideal
um
yeah
yeah and then
but and this is
okay but
it's still um
like a lot of women will see this as
like somewhat of a drawback like they
i'd say women would find this all right
especially if he's compensating with a
lot of height and face but like
obviously i'd say still this is highly
desirable as opposed to this
okay yeah
but then for women
wait gone i was gonna say in general
yeah yeah like
from our last year because
supposedly like you're supposed to be
well you're the one who finds men
attractive so you should be able to
speak on this quite accurately like
would you if a man had a body like this
but he was like
seven
seven point five in the face or maybe a
little bit more with six foot free hyatt
would you see this as a reason to reject
him or would you find that this is okay
no that's fine if he's still taller but
then it would be a bonus if he if he had
this then you would see that as like a
little like maybe a little boost like
0.5 to an extra point
um yeah maybe but like to me that that's
not that important
okay uh and lastly like so it's safe the
same guy was if he was like a six in the
face um but had this uh
body and he was still six foot free like
would this be a reason to reject him or
no
um not for me no oh so you would
actually find this
okay
yeah that'd be fine how about other
women um
would you say other women would be like
significantly turned off on this like
would they be able to imagine this guy
on top of them in bed
i mean i think it depends on how big
like the girl is
so does that make sense so like
the girl is bigger than him probably
like
so if a girl had that if the girl had
this body uh would she see this is
unacceptable like a big one
in general i would say no
yeah sorry yes it would be unacceptable
in general yeah okay but in your
personal opinion you don't uh believe
that this is as much of an issue if he's
compensating with like heightened faith
obviously yeah true
like realistic than like other girls so
oh no
i think you're gonna get i think you're
gonna get in the comments again um
people are gonna be like oh she just
pulled the um i'm not like other girls
yeah
no okay but this is what i mean like
i've had like done like
um
have you heard of like photo feeler
like where they like literally
like i've done stuff like that so i'm
not like
you know i i don't i don't think most
girls seek out that information
so do you think you have a more
realistic approach to attracting yes as
compared with most women because yeah
because i i understand a little bit more
like i think if most girls knew the 2080
rule like they would move a little bit
differently you know
yeah okay yeah that uh that makes sense
um
now moving on to the women so
what would you say
most men would find like the most
desirable
so she had to put numbers like what
would you say so if for this like if we
went one two three like what would you
say is for this
um i'd say the girl in the middle is
probably the most desirable
um
on the left than the girl on the right
i would say probably joint first again
people watching the video like uh you
feel free to leave in the comments what
you think i would say joint first but
this is like significantly less
attractive
but these bodies are like both i'd say
eight plus
maybe nine
um but then this
four
yeah
um
so the comparison that i
tried to make in the video was that
so we oh
so these two got people on the left
um
both lean both low body fat percentage
the two people in the middle um again
like average like we're talking about 15
to 16 body fat but the interesting point
that i was going to make is that this is
highly acceptable like 99 of men are
going to be
highly accepting of this figure but i'd
say
um the majority of women
they might not necessarily see this as a
reason to reject a man especially if
he's got the height and face to
compensate but
still most women would prefer this body
the vast majority of women would prefer
this body over over uh this one
yeah i agree
but it's not a huge factor like i still
i still stand with the thing that it's
only like 20 of the
equation because height is going to have
more of a more of an impact
yeah i agree with you
so
going back to women what would you say
like the percentages are for
them
based on your experience
um like for what guys look for in women
yeah yeah
um
maybe
like
20
other
like including everything so not just
looks are you doing like the whole thing
yeah i'm including everything okay did
you not want me to um i was gonna i was
implying like just the looks first and
then maybe we could have asked you
that's actually right yeah we'll ask
both questions so first just looks like
in terms of height body face what would
you say
oh hi body face okay
um for
i would say it's like maybe 10 height
um body or face 50 40 body maybe
yeah i'd say similar percentages
actually
i'd say maybe
60 face
35 body five
height like heights almost irrelevant
for yeah most women unless like you're
on the extreme echelons of either end
like because obviously like if a woman
is
like four foot ten
or shorter than that then
a lot of men would perceive that as um
less attractive or lower status likewise
if a woman is like six foot two then
um
not they might not necessarily find her
less attractive however they might find
her less approachable if that makes
sense
no i agree
i mean i've seen too many of my tall
like six foot plus friends have no
trouble finding boyfriends as long as
they pretty face
so
like i i don't think height is a big
deal
in your experience would you say um have
you ever had women like complain that
the height is a factor that um like
because of like one of your friends who
is like six foot two or something does
she ever say like oh i barely ever get
approached because of my height but
women who are short much shorter than me
like they have it easy have you ever
heard of that
no um i would say if there's any
complaint it's just if if we were
shorter like there would be more options
that we'd be attracted to but um
does that make sense but yeah so again
you're saying that
yeah so again like you're saying it's
you
seeing other men as inferior rather than
the other way around yes correct
okay so yeah we've spoken quite a lot
about this so going back to the other
question that was going to ask her so
for women including everything so
including money including looks
including personality including like all
parts of the equation what would you say
you percentage-wise like makes up a
woman's smv
wait sorry you said money personality
and looks those three i was just like
listing off various things but like if
you have more things to include so if
you think that a
um like a woman's having a low uh counts
if you know what i mean i'm not
i'm trying to put it in as
sensitive
personality
i just put that in other like
personality femininity low body count
i'd maybe give that like
20 to 30 percent
maybe 30 percent um
looks i'd say 50.
yeah sorry what was the third thing i
forgot money oh my oh money i'd maybe do
okay 50 looks 40
like personality 10 money or personality
femininity
etc
yeah yeah but then like money's quite
irrelevant so it's
like 10
yeah would you say different differs for
men that um money is a bigger factor for
for men as compared with women
um
yeah i would say it's a bigger factor
for men
or like before women looking looking for
a man
i think
but i don't think it's as much as
everyone thinks because i don't think a
five-five guy can just get money and
then pull hoes left and right
um i still think money is 10 i'd say
money is like 10 for both
men and women but the bar is set so much
higher for men uh than it is for women
so like if a woman's working a minimum
wage job at starbucks like she's just
the one of the uh you know behind the
counter workers there i don't think
that's much of an issue like men are
still going to be hitting on her like so
easily like they're not going to find
that a big deal
but for a man like although it's still
10 of the equation
like what if he's working at starbucks
especially at the age of over 30 where i
say money actually comes more into a
play then that's kind of seen as
embarrassing like women don't see it as
attractive you know they think that it's
a bit
like why is he still working these
minimum wage jobs when like he should
have established a career or uh might be
on the right path by this point
yeah i would say it's more embarrassing
for like guys care or girls care more
about that and looking for a partner but
you're saying like the overall like
standards
are just like higher
yeah so the bar is going to be higher
for everything
uh for men's a bit for men to be seen as
attractive so you're going to need um
you're going to need good face you're
gonna need good body you're gonna need
good height you're gonna need good money
good job good status
social circles everything but for women
to be seen as attractive by men like
they need to be like past a certain
looks threshold which i'd still say is
like quite low like maybe four
obviously depending on the man's looks
as well um like maybe four and then as
long as she's reasonable in a like
personality like she
is quite feminine um like reasonably low
count then the majority of men
would um see that as a like very ideal
option to date
yeah i could see that
what else do i have
yeah no i definitely think women have
like a million things that they want
where men have just like a couple much
more compact yeah yeah
so going back to like the original
question that we were speaking about
um
does that make it harder for men to get
relationships with women
or is it still like men who are the one
restricting relationships
um
i don't know when you put it like that i
could definitely
i would say it's harder for the average
guy to get a relationship than the
average girl
yeah
but a lot a point that a lot of um
people in the um
pink pill movement that's like the black
pill equivalent for women they argue
that
they're not satisfied in
uh like if you're an average woman you
can't get the relationship they
necessarily want so they only their
options are like these average tier guys
um and they don't want them they can't
get the relationships with these guys
good height good face good body
oh so so they're like mad that they
can't get their relationship with them
yeah it is i was like it's not a major
point i was pretty much just
some uh trying to sign out like with
this yeah that's what i think this
explains
um
so if we look at the wider picture
actually before we go to that um i just
wanted to go
back to a point that we touched on a
little bit so
when it comes to
aging like fine wine because i've heard
this point made in a previous uh stream
do you think that the percentages change
for
uh
the importances for men as they age
and what they look for as they age no in
what women are looking for
so the big argument i've heard been
being made is that once men reach their
30s or definitely 40s
is that status
and money
increase in importance
but meanwhile for yes so like based on
my experience like i'm a lot younger
than a lot of my audience members but
based on my experience i would say
all throughout high school things like
that
money and status didn't really carry
that much of an impact because when
you're a teenager or in your low 20s it
doesn't really matter if you have a low
paying job or
something like that or if you're low
status women like looks is pretty pretty
much like
at least eighty percent of the equation
there
and money's going to be like less than
five percent but once you're but
the arguments are being heard made
especially by men in their 30s is that
once you reach over 30 then looks drops
a little bit to maybe 50 60
and then the rest is mostly about your
status and money
um so is it
sorry i'm just trying to think about
that for a second would you say that's
for attracting like women in their 30s
or younger women yeah
yeah so so age-matched um women
age-matched women
um i would say when women get because
i'm trying i'm thinking of like my
sister um for like this is who i'm
thinking of um like she married the the
guy who like looked good but then they
ended up like divorcing because he
wasn't a good husband so then like the
second time around like she found a guy
that was a lot more like dependable and
like kind you know
oh so as she age or after she got
divorced she was then more lenient on
looks and then she looked for
um money and status more
yeah um
but i don't think that like 22 to 25
year olds are
dying to date these 35 to 50 45 year
olds like the kevin samuels of the
internet seem to think that's that's
what i mean because that's like the
highest you know i would say would you
say that's like the highest for girls or
maybe 19 to 25.
i'd say 19 to 25 year olds are mainly
looking at the men in
their low to higher 20s i think like 30
is
almost like as much of a death sentence
um as it is for women
in terms of like the drop drops in smv
oh i don't think so i think um it's more
40s for men or late 30s
so you'd say that um
men so
men get worse so both men and women get
worse as they age but
it gets like the the differences
in drops are much more severe for women
so men men um like
still maintain a bit of their chance but
women's like plummet faster
um well i think women have more options
overall so i think like if they're
they're gonna drop from what they once
were
does that make sense but overall like
the average guy isn't gonna have that
many options in general
yeah i think that's a good way of
putting it because
it was similar to what i was going to
say so
i think yeah so if a woman goes from 20
to 35 she's probably going to go from
like
500 options down to like 30 options but
for a man it's gonna drop to like three
options down to one option
yeah
yeah um
i wish i had a like another similar
thing to like one of these images like
he explained it perfectly it was some
tinder experiment some guy did uh and
the woman at hand was like in her 60s or
something and she was still getting
plenty of matches but
like obviously like nowhere near as much
as a like a younger woman would like a
woman in her 20s like the drop was
significantly severe but i'd say for men
like they're going to go from like five
matches per month to to like zero
matches by the time they're 60.
well and that's why because i remember
being 21 or 22 and going on a date with
a guy that was 32 and just thinking oh
this is so weird he's so old and so
that's why it really confused me when i
hear about all these young girls that
are apparently like chasing 45
sorry you caught a fraction
uh where did i cut off at uh you was
gonna make i believe he was gonna make
the point that
um
like the
cut off
um is
no yeah yeah no you said about like so
when you were dating a man who was 10
years older than you when you was at 21
you believe that was strange weird
unacceptable
but you had doubts in your mind and then
that's what happened
yeah but that's what i remember like
thinking that was so weird and being
like less into him because of how old he
was
um but i think after the age of maybe
like 25 ish it's like age becomes less
of a factor for women
but that's also when they start to like
drop in their smv yeah at what age would
you say women reach their peak
attractiveness
in men's eyes
maybe like
23 24.
um yeah i mean
like personally
i was going to say personally like i
think most of me and my friends peaked
at like 19 if i'm gonna be honest
yeah because you go to college so
there's a lot of like unhealthy
decisions you make in college
um
but
and like i don't know you start to see
wrinkles a little bit at like 21.
20 on it
yeah that's when i noticed my first like
crow's feet to be honest it was small
like barely a man wouldn't notice it but
girls do we noticed that kind of stuff
geez wrinkles that would be bringing
alarm bells if
that was me
because if you think
getting rid of 21 what's it going to be
like when you reach
30 like it's gonna get exponentially
worse
and i'm somewhat i don't even go out in
the sun like that too like i literally
avoid the sun
but oh my gosh all the girls are like
tan and stuff they're gonna look so bad
when they're old
you think that tanning is a detriment to
a woman's attitude oh i know it is every
no no it makes them look better in the
short term like a girl that tans but um
long term that it's so bad for your skin
every dermatologist i've ever been to or
anyone that like takes care of their
skin or looks good at an old age they've
all said sunscreen stay out of the sun
okay yeah fair enough that's an
interesting point
oh what was i just going to go back to
yeah yeah yeah um you said that the
peak attractiveness age for women is 24.
i would say that it's slightly lower
than that i would say about 21 but there
might also be other factors at play so
obviously if they like men
see women
younger like
particularly younger like even 19 20 21
because they believe they're more pure
like there's also an element of that
like they're much less likely to have a
higher count
combat so the woman who's 24 years old
might not necessarily be less attractive
less physically attractive because the
age-related
uh effects of um reducing attractiveness
haven't really kicked in
that much
but i think there might be other factors
at play such as um more purity having a
lower count things like that yeah so
they see younger women is more innocent
yeah no i mean i think the real drop off
is like i like feel like women slightly
decline until maybe like 27 28 where
it's like slightly less and less every
year but i think around 30 is when it
becomes more steep
yeah yeah i agree with that like they
drop off after 30 like it's
exponentially bad so it's going to be
fairly flat like you're probably going
to like let's say
20 years old you have like 100 of
attractiveness at 25 it's going to go to
like 95 at 30 it's down to 80. then by
the time you hit 35 it's 50 40 is like
yeah 30 so like just it just lowers and
lowers faster and faster and faster as
like women age more
yeah i guess it's downhill from here
[Music]
yeah the last point i was going to make
before i move on to something else like
how do you think height ties in to this
aging uh
like sort of thing so does hype become
more important as
um a man ages like the women more
looking for the six foot two guy as they
go over 30. like i've heard that
argument been made a few times
um i mean i think the older women get
like the more they try to actually get
what they can
actually get like when they want a ring
they kind of start to shop a little more
realistically
so that's why like they might
you know say okay whatever height can go
as long as he has this this and this
because she can't get everything well so
you think it decreases um like the
importance of height decreases as a man
as a man or woman ages
so she's gonna be less picky
yeah i mean i think the older women get
they get less picky because they want to
ring oh fair enough yeah i was just like
i was more so alluding to the point but
i've heard it in a couple of the comment
sections on my on my videos that like
when a man is like 16 17 and the women
are 16 17 in high school like they're
not really concerned about height as
much like they're also just looking for
a pretty face it's like if a man is like
five nine and he's got a really
attractive face like he's a uh you know
like
harry styles like typeface justin bieber
like you know the
have you have you ever heard of the term
pretty boys yeah sure yeah yeah so so
that they're not really concerned about
uh height as much they're more
concerned with
um
a good face with like a
really luscious like healthy looking
hair with a good hairline
like
um
so how do you know anything that your
songs have changed
um over time
yeah consid compared to when you were a
teenager to what you want now oh my god
nobody i didn't date when i was a
teenager um like i
i'm trying to think i mean i would say
yeah a little bit um
yeah i would say
like
i mean
when you're in college it's not there's
not really anything to do with career or
success because nobody is successful or
career driven you know
but when you're post college you kind of
look at that a little bit more oh so
status of money does like increase in
importance after college
i would say yeah would you say and would
you
um so that your standards like change
more because the general idea that i've
often heard in like the blackpool
community is that women go for the
pretty boys in their teens in high
school but then once they turn like 22
23 they think they they look back on
themselves and they think gross why why
did i think that guy was attractive like
he's way too
cute he's like not masculine he's not
attractive and and their standards
changed more like uh the chad the chad
uh type so like these guys
do you think women's standards get like
higher the older they get no not higher
but they change from a
uh i'll share the screen again um okay
so
oh do i have an example
okay
i don't have an example of like
so like right so yeah so say if this guy
was
an eight like let's just say that he was
a lot more attractive like he's a bit
feminine in the face
so women are more attracted to this guy
if he was if he was an eight uh in their
teenagers and then they turn more to
these guys uh who are more masculine
like menacing looking uh when they're in
their mid-20s
um
but then they go for like more the harry
styles type uh
in their teens uh when they're
um
you know like in high school age
um
i don't know might
so what was your experience
my boyfriend now
i i would say like i have a similar type
that hasn't changed all throughout your
high school uh college period um from
college to now yeah i would say i have a
type that hasn't changed
oh
i didn't i didn't date in high school
yeah like though when he was watching
movies tv shows like was there like any
particular uh
guys that like you know you you dreamt
of like you're like oh i want this guy
to be my future husband oh he's so
dreamy like
you know like you know what i'm trying
to say like yeah yeah um
trying to think who was my
i always liked to the guy from um
what's it called
what is that show called grey's anatomy
i forget his name
um but yeah he was probably more like
feminine i would say
hmm okay yeah so so it like it does line
up there is like some truth to that
claim that i hear
i guess but he still probably would be
my celebrity crush like if i had to pick
one even even even now even now yeah
yeah
oh so that's interesting so maybe it
hasn't changed as much
um i want this stream to be like one and
a half hours long so
if we maybe move on to like the last uh
part that you suggested at the beginning
um you said you wanted like more of an
interview type
uh
yeah sure um i just wanted you to like
explain the black pill to me in like
layman's terms because i think i'm
pretty familiar with red pill and i
think i got some of that from this
interview like so far but i didn't know
if there's any points that maybe we
missed and we didn't go over
okay yeah yeah that's fine um first like
what's your take in a red pill then like
what do you think the red pill stands
for like what are their main tenets or
beliefs
um you can basic it's basically how to
become a high value man if i had to like
put it in layman's terms
and women don't like nice guys
is like the red pill that women
like the chase they like guys that don't
want them um and they also go for chats
so
yeah it's a lot of guys that are really
upset
that women basically go for chad's get
ran through and then try to go for um
they call it a beta later
do you think that's what the red pill
believes the like i was agreeing largely
after the bit you mentioned the uh like
chad's part uh but i do agree with you
that the two like main tenants of the
like two of the major tenants that have
read pill is that they want a higher
value man and they want and they don't
want a nice guy i think they're like two
major tenants but like i did i disagree
to some extent with the uh chad argument
i think that's more so
would you say better bachelor is black
girl
i'm not hugely familiar with his content
but um i know a couple of other people
have uh referenced him in other
interviews and by the sounds of it he
sounds like i think i think he's mgtow
i'm not entirely sure i don't watch his
content but i've heard that he's mgtow
or something like that
oh is that not the same thing as red
pill
yeah yeah it is it's like there's
different branches like of the
red hill like mgtow's slightly more in
line with blackpill as compared with
like pua like have you heard of pua
uh pick-up artists yeah yeah so
that's like
more strongly tied to the red pill i
would say in in the respect that it's
trying to teach men to become a high
value man and not being the nice guy so
learning all of these different uh
techniques um
what techniques like would you say that
these red pill guys uh give advice like
they give to men in order to become a
high value man oh my gosh i heard the
worst one the other day it was from
fresh and fit and he said to tell a girl
if if you're on a date with a girl and
you take her back to your place and she
says i don't want to sleep with you say
okay i need you to leave so i can like
call another girl basically like if
you're not gonna have sex with me i'm
gonna call someone else who will
really so
so what are your thoughts on that
what are my thoughts yeah
i mean i should i just thought it was
rude i mean you could tell her to leave
if you want that's fine if you don't if
that's what you want but
i don't think that's gonna work for a
guy that's a four or a three she'll
probably just be like okay
that's a very like interesting funny
point that you just raised that because
i think that is exactly where the black
bill steps in that all of these
so-called techniques like honestly if
they
if a chad did that if an 8 out of 10 you
know did the i'm gonna talk to somebody
else technique it most likely will work
for him i would say because the woman is
going to want to chase him rather than
the other way around but if a 3 out of
10 pulls the exact same move then uh
like i think that's where the black
people steps here they just say yeah
she's just gonna look back and laugh she
could be like i'm above you anyway like
there's there's no point in doing that